marij Jade was introduced as a Smuggler
who was previously employed as the
emperor's hand in the 1991 novel heir to
the Empire the first installment in
Timothy Zan's Braun Trilogy she's an
extremely skilled user of the dark side
of the force and prior to the emperor's
death mea was given the command to kill
Luke Skywalker she manages to kidnap
Luke but the two subsequently become
stranded in a harsh environment and must
work together to escape this event
starts to bring the two together and
though it takes several more novels Luke
and Mara eventually fall in love and
finally get married in the 2000
Darkhorse comic Star Wars Union but
that's not the end of their story Luke
and Mara also have a son together named
Ben Skywalker whose first name appears
to have been recycled in the sequel
Trilogy as Ben solo AKA kylo Ren Ben
Skywalker grows up to become an
accomplished Jedi like his mom but Mara
doesn't live to see it she's murdered by
her nephew Jason solo while he's on his
way to becoming Darth kitis